hi in this video we would look at
intracellular receptors now we have
already seen receptors displays on the
cell surface and how they work in this
entire cell signaling playlist now we'll
look at a different type of receptor
which is known as intracellular receptor
as the name suggests they are present in
the intracellular site either in the
cytoplasm or in the nucleus they have
unique structural features which we
would be discussing in this video along
with that we would discuss their
functions first let's discuss their
structure a little bit the unique
feature about nuclear receptor is they
have intrinsic transcription factor
activity like in case of growth
signaling pathways and receptor tyrosine
kinase we found that the receptor has
intrinsic enzymatic activity intrinsic
tyrosine kinase enzyme emetic activity
in this case we find the receptor has an
intrinsic transcription factor activity
which might lead to transcription
activation and it can bind to the DNA so
the receptor itself can bind to the DNA
in an elegant dependent manner if we
look at the genetic sequence of it we
would see it is distributed in several
domains namely a /p e c d e and f and we
look at what these domains do first of
all the AF 1 and the AF 2 domains
interact with the RNA polymerase and the
general transcription factors so they
are also known as transcription
activation domains the gain binding
domain is the most important one which
bind to the ligands and this ligand
binding lead to dimerization either
homodimer ization or heterodimerization
which we would look at in this video now
the important most domain is the tener a
binding domain now the DB D has the DNA
binding feature and we would look at
what is the DNA binding structure so
from this structure when it is
transcribed and
slated it forms the nuclear receptor
protein complex which has the and now in
this particular view we are seeing a
receptor monomer which is able to bind
the ligand in the ligand binding domain
or a dimerization domain now the DNA
binding domain consists of zinc finger
motif now Singh finger motif is an
important DNA binding domain wanted to
know more about the zinc finger motifs
and other DNA binding domain the link of
this video is given at the end of n
screen now the zinc finger motif which
is present in the DNA binding domain
binds to the major groove of the DNA and
several groups projecting out from the
zinc finger domain alpha helices
actually interact with the bases present
in the major groove and depending upon
the bases that are projecting out of
these alpha helices determine the
sequence basic specificity where these
nuclear receptors actually bind and they
bind to a specific region known as
hormone response element which we would
learn in a moment so far we have seen
signal transduction paradigms where the
began binds to the extracellular
receptor which is displayed on the
membrane surface so the ligand is
external ligand and then a cascade of
second messenger and many other
intermediate molecules relay the signal
to the nucleus which might lead to a
transcriptional change but in case of
nuclear receptor things are different
the ligand can bind getting inside the
cell so the ligand is freely diffusible
from the membrane and we would learn
about the ligand in a moment but at
normal stage States there are two
different kinds of intracellular
receptor 1 which is reciting in the
cytoplasm such as this particular
receptor once it is residing in the
cytoplasm it is in an inactivated state
and that is stabilized by it
protein 19 but when ligand bind to it
and in this case the ligand can easily
pass through the cell membrane and can
directly enter the cytosol there is a
shift of hsp90 and hsp90 dissociates
from the complex as a result this ligand
binary scepter is free to translocate
into the nucleus once it is in the
nucleus it can interact with the RNA
polymerase 1 and the RNA pol and the
general transcription factor which would
ultimately lead to transcriptional
activation so we can clearly understand
that ligand mediated transcriptional
activation is the mode of action of
nuclear receptors now if we look
carefully and in a lot more details
about the nuclear receptors we
understand that there are several motifs
on to the DNA where these intracellular
receptors can bind for example if we
talk about estrogen receptor there would
be a estrogen response element which is
a specific hexameric sequence followed
by a gap and another hexameric repeat
sequences and in this particular
sequence feature the zinc finger motif
of the receptors actually bind they
generally bind in format of a homo dimer
in case of these steroid receptors the
homo dimers first bind to the lily
ligand then they translocate as a dimer
into the nucleus where they can lead to
transcriptional activation now there are
other kind of nuclear receptors which
are already present in the nucleus their
intracellular receptor but moreover
their nuclear receptor they are not
located in the cytoplasm so they're
located in the nucleus sitting on the
DNA waiting for the ligand to bind but
while they are not bound to the ligand
they are generally bound with the
repressor complex such that
transcription cannot happen at that
moment but the moment when the ligand is
binding to the receptor the receptor the
repressor complex
is dissociated as a result of depression
RNA polymerase can bind and other
general transcription can bind to the
DNA and that lead to transcriptional
activation looking at a lot more details
to it we would understand most most
mostly these receptors are actually
heterodimer retinoic acid receptor and
it's family fall under these classes
just like estrogen receptors and other
steroid receptors it has specifically
nuoc acid response element where it
binds but in it forms generally a
heterodimer only one of the heterodimer
one of the monomer of these heterodimer
complex bind to the ligand the other
doesn't bind to the ligand now when the
ligand is not bound at that particular
situation the whole nuclear the nuclear
receptor complex is bound to a cone
repressor mostly the co-repressor is
found to be ncor and SMRT in case of
retinoic acid receptor these are just
names but these imagine these are
co-repressor complexes mostly they are
associated with histone deacetylase
which can really diaz it I like the
chromatin near this region and make that
chromatin more compact and inappropriate
for transcriptional start now let's see
what happens when the ligand binds when
the ligand binds that leads to a
conformational change in this whole
complex a portion of this complex has
III ubiquitin ligase activity which
ubiquitin annihilate a particular
portion of this ncor when it is poly u
be annihilated it is degraded by
ubiquitin proteasome mediated pathway so
the co-repressor complex falls off
actually
now when the repressor complex is gone
in presence of ligand the activator or
the co-activator can bind to this dimer
along with this co-activator several
components such as histone acetyl
transferase histone methyl transferase
nucleus
remodelers etc can bind to it we can
name that an activator complex as you
can understand histone acetyl
transferase would acetylated the
histones near this region making the
chromatin more accessible towards the
transcription factors histone
methyltransferase can also transfer
several methylation to the histone
residues which are active a tree
nucleosome remodeling change the spacing
and change the density of the
nucleosomes freeing up a space for
transcriptional start as a result of
this activator complex binding the
general transcription factors and the
RNA pol 2 can bind to the original bind
to the promoter and lead to
transcription activation now we pretty
much covered the mechanism at least the
basics of it how nuclear receptor works
at a molecular level let's take an
example that these two distinct paradigm
were we calling the first one as a
cytoplasmic receptors with a new
receptor is it residing in a cytoplasm
let her get translocated into the
nucleus and second one with the receptor
is already in the nucleus and waiting
for the ligand to bind for starting the
transcription so glucocorticoid
mineralocorticoid androgens
progesterones and vitamin d fall under
the first category of cytoplasmic
receptor both of these categories are
actually interested in receptors whereas
the retinoic acid receptor thyroid
receptors PPAR and liver x receptor all
these things falls under the nuclear
receptor category we also discussed the
similarity and dissimilarity of mode of
action of these two different regimes of
intracellular receptor pathways now have
you ever wonder that
while the difference between major
groups signaling pathways and nuclear
receptor signaling pathway so the growth
signaling pathways takes a lot of time
because there are so many intermediate
mediators that conveyed a signal to the
nucleus whereas nuclear receptor
signaling is pretty fast right
it saves the cell are a lot of time it
is a quick
Bonz but the problem is it doesn't have
a signal amplification capability now
can you think about that why the cell at
all need a growth factor signaling which
is little bit slower and if the cell has
a option to use a signalling paradigm
which is way more faster and quick
important for quick response why at all
we have signal amplification system the
whole answer lies in the demand there
are many cases where the ligand is less
and you need to really amplify the
signal coming from the ligand in order
for the nucleus to understand some of
the cases the ligand might be abundant
in that situation signal amplification
is not required rather than a fast and
quick response is preferred we would
learn about about more of these kind of
discussions in a different video but for
now we're pretty much done with the
concept of nuclear receptor and how they
work at a molecular level so I hope this
in video was informative and if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and thanks for listening please comment
and your comment give me so much
motivation to make new videos so don't
forget to comment thank